hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
who are you I'm Kat Alvarado Kat
Alvarado's back with Greg and apparently
she watched his Game of Thrones and
Monday night we're shooting this these
promos drop today so I was like awesome
let's check this out just as a heads up
I am going to be covering Game of
Thrones hired an editor to do the ten
minute reaction highlights cuts that we
could put them up on YouTube hopefully
they don't get blocked but Kat Alvarado
I went on her brand new podcast Dix of
history history I was on there you can
listen to it on iTunes well your your
podcast and make it linked to this I
will I will plug my podcast so villains
of history is about the worst people of
history and actually if you're a game of
Thrones fan you're gonna like the most
recent episode which is called worst
uncle ever covers a couple characters
off of which I'm pretty sure Joffrey is
based now we must all listen to Kats
podcast I talked about a KKK guy and
John Wilkes Booth with cat it was a
great time I learned some history yes
this guy knows more yeah I know just as
about as much as Wikipedia will let me
know I want everybody to know more I get
most my information from it's like
Lapita Britannica that's step up from
Wikipedia let's watch this move we got
two promos here we'll watch them
back-to-back survival and together
Oh Starwood survival
oh yeah ed Ned started
would you might connect to it right away
they're so short I like it that way all
right
they flash that image a couple times
it must be they're awkward okay first
things first I think we see that Aria is
gonna die what they wouldn't show them
the trailer show me she's gonna come
freaking close to dying if you go to the
first one she's running and she's got
like blood all over her face she's in
some dire straits right there I mean did
you see the other trailer we saw that in
the other trailer where's the aftermath
she's gonna come close to dying
everyone wants everyone's gonna come
close to dying in this season cat it's
the finale geez use some logic that's
true well we already know that Jamie is
gonna die how do we know that already he
basically said in a tweeter and
interview the actor said he had a
wonderful death scene I'm looking online
I can't find anything about the actor
saying that he had a wonderful death
scene I don't know what the hell she's
talking about
what yeah know what yeah total spoiler
no [ __ ] cat why would you say that to me
like you did you was really do you know
this no not even the principal so far
off in your world sure I know oh man
thanks dad that makes that makes me feel
really confident about myself it's such
a spoiler yeah I can't be true I'm gonna
look that up do it Jamie Lannister dead
I don't see anything about that all
right so here's what I ended up finding
right now he was doing an interview with
the son or the title of it was Jamie
over at game of Thrones
Nikolaj coster-waldau I've no idea how
to Brown says now give strongest and yet
that Jamie Lannister will die before
season finale okay here's
speaking to start - he revealed I had a
great last scene it was absolutely
beautiful it was a perfect way to end
obviously I can't tell you what the
scene was it wasn't the final scene of
the series but it was close to the end
it was shot at a beautiful location at
this point I'd seen quite a lot of
colleagues wrap that's a lot of Tears
beautiful speeches and I knew what to
expect so he didn't say he has a
wonderful death scene Kat Alvarado and
maybe this is hinting at the fact that
he does but he'll it's maybe ultimately
what he's saying he had a great last
scene he knew he had everyone in the
actress has a final scene in the show
it's the plaza it's the last season so
he's probably gonna die all this stuff
of like I promise if I for the living I
intend to keep that promise that all the
links to like stuff of I'm gonna die and
I like the themes that these promos are
showing us I think the marketing is so
clever for it because there's only six
episodes I believe which makes hiring an
editor very cost-efficient it says you
don't need to like really tease anything
because six is so contained enough as it
is and I'm like don't show me my I like
trailers I just Jara hone in on you know
themes and stuff so like survival having
to work together all like in unity
banding together for the one common
enemy and then sir she's on the side
yeah just fight it out and then we'll
fight whoever's left standing those kind
of elements to me what are you most
excited for in this season I just want
to find out who dies and lives I'm very
like tell me what's going on kind of a
person I really want to see if some of
the fan theories come true or not like
one of them is that Daenerys is gonna
die have you heard that yeah that's when
I don't I've heard a theory about how
each one is gonna die everyone's gonna
die I mean this is Game of Thrones so I
feel like what people are setting
themselves up for is that everything's
gonna be like this there we're finally
gonna get that triumphant ending that
Return of the King or the Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows part-2
I feel like nah it's probably I be a
little bit let down if it ends
oh look at you know John at the took at
the throne the Iron Throne Ezz
he's King now and everything as cool as
that sounds that's not his MO that's not
Martin yeah yeah exactly and he's always
about going to going against the grain
on those kind of things it's gonna be
someone we don't expect and they're
gonna be really sad or maybe there might
not be any throne ever thought about
that I like that maybe that's final line
is game over it's been like these I may
just like sit monster energy drink
what's the next one we are on the same
page about this do we see any of the ice
dragons that final image of that dragon
spirit spewing fire at us is that I
can't tell if that's the ice dragon or
not either way man that looks [ __ ]
scary it really does oh my those teeth
it's like multi-layered and like yeah
spiky it's what your teeth look like
before I do after-effects on this video
what I also really like in the promos
when you see like Sansa looking upon the
Dragons this is not her first time she's
seen the Dragons right and it brings me
back to that what that sense of wonder
of when you it's like we've done a use
of the Dragons but there's all these
other characters who still have yet to
lay eyes on them I really should try to
cram in that last season again before
this new one for me here we wrap this
video up now all right keep a lookout
for my reactions to Game of Thrones I'm
probably gonna bring someone on to cover
with us who is who's read the books just
to make things easier for us to catch
any moment because I tell you like so
many times things just fly over my head
and I'm like oh that was a piece of
important information I didn't know I
thought it was just casual dialogue they
were having with each other so yeah but
I can't wait to watch this I'm excited
for this is an event it's a television
event yes I'm gonna live-tweet this [ __ ]
oh that that's where everyone's gonna be
coming what's Kat saying about it no
never
I can't like have a few likes wow you
look great cat guys you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell follow Kat Alvarado on
social media but especially check out
our podcast yes please link be our
interview our podcasts on the I can link
it yes you can it's linked and well
catch you guys soon
mmm
well if you made it all the way to the
end I'm Kat Alvarado we're gonna do this
after math one shot those with Kat
yesterday was gonna put up this morning
Avengers drop this morning and then the
mists of the majors I had no idea that
this drops I figured gonna cap it off
and I got John here so let's watch the
aftermath tease hmm
the Nights Watch
and some needle yeah like naming
characters that's chappie Oh way way oh
there's hand Jamie's hand John snows
sort its Frodo sort for the ring testing
I love the marketing here you know what
I will say because there's a whole lot
to say is that I do like that motif of
like showing a bunch of visuals of a
scene of a place and then playing the
audio over it of a situation I've led to
this but clearly nobody's there right
now you know like I do like that as the
just oral experience I'm hoping this is
the end of the show it is i hoped i hope
i just show us the ending is like hope
everyone lost the night king one ham
it's the night kings watch now this is a
great tease to give us everything
without giving us anything
mm-hmm taking well I obviously didn't
recognize every problem yeah yeah Ari so
I think it was like brands wheelchairs
and at one point who has like a FAL fat
the feather right yeah comment if you
made it this far comment all the Easter
eggs a feather I'm like wait I it's like
right there my noggin somewhere if I had
just read this top comment it says the
feather robber put on the honest whom ya
wouldn't have got that we're not gonna
figure this we are Game of Thrones were
one Google search away from remembering
will get a will get someone who's more
of an expert to join us in our reactions
when we do this thank you guys
you